well the purpose of the stamp 'mobile is
to draw attention to the overall stamp
stampede campaign I think the political
change needs to be fun you know we need
to do hard important serious work in a
way that's enjoyable what we're doing
here is a service to the nation
we're adorning dollars we're beautifying
people's bucks we're making money
talking the design was by a gentleman
from Allen Rory who also did a lot of
the fabrication in terms of the the
fabrication I think one of the key
challenges was that all the modules were
tested separately but when they were
finally all put together nothing quite
work you know everything worked
separately together everything had
problems so so the I think the key
overriding challenge was this idea that
that as a system it wasn't quite there
so we've spent a lot of time figuring
out the interactions between the parts
and making sure that up that everything
does work
what is it made of the tracks are
plastic there are kind of a very
slippery plastic that's made for
plumbing and has been repurposed a lot
of hand-painted wooden parts laser-cut
parts there's even parts in there made
on a MakerBot you know pulleys motors
levers yeah you name it the first thing
that we do is that you load a dollar
bill into these Platinum's those slide
along a little plastic track onto a part
of the machine called the spiral lift
that spins them around and raises them
up at the same time at the top it
releases it and then it goes down a
track bumping into the strike plates
that trigger a couple of signs the first
one says you know corporations are not
people
the next moves aside the silhouette of a
person to reveal that it's actually a
corporation then it's another striker
that opens what we call mr. money mouths
the platen swings around the curve and
lands under the stamping mechanism where
it's held in place while a stamp comes
down and prints on the bill
and then when that's done to adjust it
on the stamping mechanism
the person put the bill in can then get
their new lease that bill back out this
is monetary jiu-jitsu it's using money
to get money out of politics